le commandant de l'armée de terre
ukrainien a dit hier que les Ukrainiens
avaient lancé une petite
contre-offensive dans batmouth et ils
avaient réussi à reprendre quelques
positions prises par les Russes dans les
jours précédentes je ne vois pas cette
contre-offensive reflétée sur les cartes
qui sont établies par les observateurs
indépendants du conflit mais bien sûr il
est très difficile vraiment de savoir
exactement qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
Batman et la situation est très fluide
dans l'ensemble il faut dire que les
Ukrainiens ont perdu du terrain dans
Batman ces derniers deux semaines il
contrôle maintenant seulement une petite
partie de la ville à l'ouest mais les
Russes n'ont pas réussi à bloquer la
route par laquelle les Ukrainiens
amènent approvisionne leur armée dans
Batman ils n'ont pas réussi à encercler
les ukrainiens et ils ne peuvent pas
dire qu'il contrôle la totalité de la
ville alors ce succès très très modeste
dont la prise de une grande partie de
batmouth mais même pas toute la ville
c'est tout ce que les Russes peuvent
afficher pour ces cinq mois de combat
dans l'est de l'Ukraine avec ses pertes
absolument extraordinaires que comme
vous avez dit bien sûr les Ukrainiens
estiment les Perthus encore plus élevés
que les renseignements américains mais
20000 morts en 5 mois essentiellement
uniquement autour de Batman c'est
vraiment des pertes extrêmement
importantes pour les Russes il ne faut
pas bien sûr oublier que les Ukrainiens
ont subi des pertes très importantes
aussi et aussi un niveau de fatigue et
de stress pour leurs hommes une grande
partie des combattants à baccout sont à
batmouth pendant toute cette bataille il
n'y a pas eu beaucoup de rotation pour
beaucoup d'entre eux il y a deux jours
ou même non loin d'ici j'ai rencontré
deux combattants Ukrainiens qui avaient
été un pakmouth qui était deux ou ils
étaient rentrés à human pour enfin se
reposer juste avant cette frappe qui a
touché
Oman il y a quelques jours et à discuté
avec ces hommes pendant juste quelques
minutes j'ai très vite compris que
c'était des hommes profondément
traumatisés non pas seulement par la
frappe sur Roumane mais peur tous les
mois qu'ils avaient qu'ils avaient
combattu à batmouth les forces
ukrainiennes ceux qui ont été abattement
c'est une grande partie d'entre eux sont
extrêmement extrêmement fatigué je pense
que beaucoup d'entre eux ont besoin
d'une attention psychologique